[Music]
welcome to the semi elites podcast my
name is Erin on bonus we're gonna be
talking about setting goals and make you
2020 the best you're ever so as a
businessman someone who is focused on
making money adding value to people's
lives right one of the things that I
find is making money is 1-dimensional
it's not enough you've got to have a
place to put the money and I find that
real estate is exciting so from your
perspective what made you get into real
estate yeah I mean how did you what was
the trigger a really interesting I got
into real estate before I got into
business so a lot of people like
yourself you made millions of pounds in
business yeah and then will I I need to
do something with this money now yeah I
know I'll invest in its property which
is really cool but with me it was more
like and I have any money and I have a
business so I started from scratch and
it was Rich Dad Poor Dad Robert
Kiyosaki's book that got me they've got
me into a life-changing book yeah yeah
and of course once you read Rich Dad
Poor Dad you're kind of ruined a bit
like how people watch my YouTube videos
or read my book and I say I'm ruined you
read Rich Dad Poor Dad Sonny everything
that you thought about business
investments money freedom it's just
turned on its head and I thought I need
to get into real estate it's funny you
say that everything you read about money
and everything you know it gets turned
on your head and you become ruined
because growing up as a kid I heard
things like money doesn't grow on trees
money doesn't grow on trees and then I
got a little bit older and then I
discovered that money was paper where
does paper come from it comes from trees
so they kind of ruined mean that said
they're like what everything I've been
told is being a myth a story you talk
about Robert Kiyosaki I had obviously
like yourself the blessing and
opportunity to share the stage with him
multiple times and his wonderful wife
Kim she's an amazing individual and it's
funny because when I shared the stage
with him a couple of years ago I
remember telling Robert that Rich Dad
put it like yourself was one of the big
inspirations for me to create financial
freedom passive income and eventually to
invest into property yes
very interesting that we have that
commonly you know what we have to really
thank Robert Kiyosaki B I know he's a
bit of a grumpy old man now because yes
you know he's sometimes I mean when you
when you look up someone so much and you
meet them in they're a bit like Robert
Kiyosaki's a little bit grumpy and when
I first met him I was like wow but
actually I've got real respect for him
because even when I've run a training
event now there's a thousand people in
the room I'll say I started with rich
dad poor dad put your hand up if you
read the book and honestly at least half
the hounds go up and then I'll say into
the other half you need to go read the
book you know so I think me and you both
ready for so of so many people and I
think that's one of the the things that
are lost today I find that a lot of
people they want to achieve results but
they're not willing to commit to that
educational side of things yeah to read
a book go to a class go to a seminar you
know come to a crash course you know all
these things are so important I mean I'm
sitting in front of you I didn't finish
school I didn't go to no University no
rich mama no rich daddy you know and
everything that I've created like you
said making millions in business you
know having the financial success that I
have today it all came through self
education knowing that I was intended to
do great things but if I didn't open up
the book if I didn't take the seminar if
I didn't take the course I would never
achieve it and Robert Kiyosaki kind of
put me on that path of asking questions
understanding that there's more than the
9:00 to 5:00 9:00 to 5:00 until you're
65 yeah and so this is what I love the
commonality of sitting with you
obviously we spend dated today together
you know looking at deals looking at
properties but also understanding that
there's so many cool ways to make money
other than being that slave yeah and
property is a great way to live leverage
our energies yeah so let me ask you a
question because obviously I'm curious
about your journey in your path you
bought your first property age of 17 yes
right you became financially free in
your young twenties that's not normal
you understand that right it's if not
normal although I've changed what normal
is for many people exactly so having
that background having that story you
obviously meet a lot of people at events
they come up to you what are the common
things that they say is it inspiration
what do they take from your story people
come to me all the time and stop me in
the street
say that they've become financially free
as a result of my training or my videos
or people say you know I've just bought
HMO my wife just quit work we've just it
happens all the time and I think that
it's a phenomenal feeling for me and
you'll see this as we hang around a bit
but as we start to go around together
I'm not just talking to training events
I'm talking I get stopped in the street
in London and people don't come up to me
and say I love watching your videos it's
always I've done there so I've done that
and man it's it's incredible so that's
that I think the way that I teach even
if you watch my videos but especially if
you you know especially if you come to a
training program you are gonna get
results you have no choice because
you're put in an environment where it's
it's not a seminar it's a do or not
doing it and that's one of the things
that I switch your crash course which
was phenomenal because a lot of these
people you come to a seminar you sit
there you take notes you go home and
three four days later you don't remember
anything you learnt yeah what I love
about the crash course is really it's
not a seminar to do an are you rolling
up your sleeves you doing the work you
literally leaving there with the
possibility and the potential to create
a business in a box yeah and that's only
on day one and so that's forming I loved
about all I wouldn't have bought my
first house at 17 if I hadn't had
massive problems because the massive
problems here's the thing all I was
thinking when I'm 18 I'm gonna buy a
house and I was 17 and I was getting
more all these training courses and I
was learning how to do it I was thinking
as soon as I'm 18 I'm gonna do a no
money down deal and I've learnt the
strategies and then my mortgage broker
told me you've got to be 21 to get by to
let mortgage so I'm like I'm not waiting
for years so I found a solution which
was to put my property in someone else's
name in the family they're almost like a
guarantor and then I thought what if I'm
gonna do that why even wait till I'm 18
why not just do it now at 17 and a
massive obstacle that could have held me
about four years actually enabled me to
start immediately and I think that
that's just flipping the cards it's
funny you say they're flipping the cards
you know we in one of the things that I
teach in some of the programs that I
that I that I you know share and and
travel around the world teaching people
how to to financial freedom
it's always about perspective where one
person sees crisis the other person sees
opportunity
and you know it's really about changing
the way you look at things where some
people would see that as a downfall and
say oh I've got a certain went till I'm
21 go get a job work it out and in
reality get stuck into that lifestyle
and eventually possibly never get a
property you saw that as okay there's a
problem here's the situation I see this
as an opportunity you use it as fuel to
move you forward I think that's so cool
and as funny you say that you had
problems because I feel that a lot of
people they have problems but they have
problems but they don't have enough pain
yeah sure and I think if people had more
pain or if they came to understand more
that paying the price of doing the
nine-to-five until you're 65 that price
of having to wake up every morning going
to a job you don't like to impress
people you don't like to work with
people you don't like to get a paycheck
that you don't like that price doing
that for 20 30 40 years that price is so
heavy and if they were to take that and
stimulate that and put that into a
concept of wow this is gonna be a
painful journey unless I change and then
they focus on let's say investing on
property coming to a crash course
learning those tools learning the
secrets and putting that energy behind
becoming financially free through
property that journey can be sure that
can be a six 12 18 month journey to
being in a place where they never have
to work again yeah sure but some people
expect it to be a six day journey or
they'll all they'll Matt I mean we've
been making a lot of course today to
estate agents but we got rejected right
yeah absolutely pick up the phone and
we'd get laughed out or the agent would
say are you they're never going to
accept that offer and we just politely
say well thank you so much for your time
if anything changes give me a call back
next but people get one rejection or
they or they spend six days when they
need to spend six months or 18 months
and they don't get the results that they
want because they watch my financial
freedom challenge in a week or now even
more recently in a day you watch that
right insane in says the best thing
about it it's funny you say though the
best thing about it was in the beginning
of the program where you said okay let's
go and you were like I don't even know
where we're going yeah and I think as
long as
you trust yourself things will unfold
the first thing you said in their
program okay we're gonna get started all
I have is my laptop back yeah and my
laptop let's go and then literally a
second later you say I don't even know
where I'm going yeah you know as long as
you trust yourself and you take action
yeah things are gonna happen you know
what it's funny in the Bible I know
you're Jewish as well yeah Old Testament
yeah it says about Abraham it says that
Abraham went out not knowing where he
was going in faith and I think that
success in business you do need faith
and faith is seeing the unseen something
that doesn't exist yet
but seeing it and being prepared to go
not know where you're going because the
thing is the most dangerous position to
be standing is standing still if you're
going if you're moving then you can you
can be guided you can figure things out
you can change direction but if you're
standing still waiting for all the
traffic lights to be on green before you
step out the house you're gonna be there
for a very long time you know it's funny
you say that I recently wrote an article
in a magazine about the power of belief
and you know we spent the day together
we were working obviously you were
showing me some great tools and methods
to find properties source properties we
were making calls together and a little
bit earlier I was wearing a t-shirt and
on the t-shirt it actually said
billionaire in the making yeah and when
I travel with his t-shirt it's just a
t-shirt right
but it says billion in the making when I
travel with this t-shirt when I'm at an
airport or about to board a plane and I
have this t-shirt on I always get people
looking at me like I'm crazy and what's
funny is is that I always say that if
you believe believe you're already
halfway there yeah and a lot of people
lack that belief and so when people give
me some weird looks about wearing that
shirt billion a in the making
actually all they showing is their
limitation not mine and so if more
people had that belief in themselves I
believe that more people would achieve
greater results you know I want to I
want to get one of those t-shirts man
you inspired me to get one of those
t-shirts and
if believing you're halfway there but
then disbelieving you're a hundred
percent the other way exactly if you if
you if you don't believe you can do
something you can have the right and it
is interesting because sometimes when
I'm training people it can be two people
sat together same training same content
same tools they say it's the same
they're both broke neither of them have
got any money six months later one of
them is financially free the other
person still moaning and whinging about
their job no different and it's like why
is that I mean what do you think you're
a trainer it's funny you say because I
see that all the time to people same
tools same strategies same everything
one goes out skyrockets to success the
other one not much happens to them I
think it's great to have tools it's
great to have belief it all boils down
to taking action at the end of the day I
believe that the greatest treasures on
planet Earth or reserved for the action
takers yeah 100% and so if you educate
yourself you take the course you take
the seminar you read the book and you
combine that with action success in is
inevitable mmm it is inevitable it's
just a question of time it's you know
there's I believe there's no unrealistic
goals they're only unrealistic timelines
yeah and so you know to acquire property
like you said you know whether you're
seventeen eighteen or twenty-one
there's no unrealistic goal there's only
unrealistic timeline yeah but it's funny
because I agree with us so much about
action and taking taking action to get
results and but the thing is that's why
my training programs I actually make
people take action there and then so
it's not like but those people say I
don't want to call the agent just give
me more content just teach me more no no
I'm not teaching you anything until you
picked up the phone and made that phone
call yeah because that's the best way to
learn and creating an environment for
people to do that I'm passionate man and
and obviously their passion is something
that overflows and I've seen that over
and over again spending the day with you
and you you know you talk about action
picking up the phone if people would
treat this game like any other game
because it is a game of just picking up
the phone making a connection building a
relationship you know introducing
yourself and stating what you want and
and how you want to achieve it
people will respond to you not everyone
and the question is are you willing to
be rejected 99 times two here one years
and I think that's one of the things
when people say to me are known how have
you become financially free coming from
a family with you know my father left
when I was a kid and you know I spoke
about this a little bit earlier I I
didn't grow up with the silver spoon in
my mouth or you know of that stuff but
one of the key things that I've always
been a big believer in is just take
action yeah take action
you know things will happen people will
show up and trust I think a lot of
people lack trust in themselves today
and it's it's actually a phenomenon I
see it as a negative phenomenon people
have lost trust in themselves they're
lost believed because there's endless
amount of people saying you're not good
enough you're not tall enough you're not
short enough you're not this enough
you're not that enough and it's so easy
to buy into that concept and so for
example in my home and this is me this
is very personal very private in my home
in my shower I have some declarations
that are in the shower laminated with
just some very powerful statements that
I I have up there every time I'm gonna
take a shower in the morning or in the
night before I go to bed I allow those
words those affirmations if you will
those positive statements to feed my
subconscious and you become what you
repeat hmm and so all these things are
just feeding me because people buy into
that I'm not good enough I don't have
the money you know all this stuff and
like Henry Ford said whether you believe
you can whether you believe you can't
either way you are right yeah so
obviously property is your passion and
I've seen that through and through
spending time with you today what would
you say has been one of the biggest
mistakes you've made that now you can
look back in a law that and say well was
a great lesson for me yeah it's funny
because when you think of mistakes you
can you can often look at times when
you've lost money Oh
assuming it's gone bad but sometimes I
think some of my biggest mistakes have
been where I've actually left money on
the table when I've not done a deal when
I should in a deal
or where I when I've not I've used all
of my own money and tidy up when I could
have done 10 deals and used to the
people's money and that's one of the the
big mistakes of 2019 last year I felt
like I could have my reputation was
really good my brand was good lots of
people knew who I was but I wasn't I
wasn't really on the property side
buying anywhere near the kind of amount
properties I could have been doing I
mean I was 29 houses but they're all
small houses and I realized that a small
house takes just as much effort as a big
house so I kind of wish that I'd had the
balls and the courage to go into bigger
deal sooner because I've realized when
you play the game cashflow one I want
yes it's the big deals that most make
the most money so I think that's
probably something I wish I'd learned a
bit sooner I wish a little bit more
courage I was doing my attitude was if
it's not broken don't fix it I know that
these small girls are working I was
going to keep doing them all scale if by
the big deals it was only when I bought
the castle in June 2018 and I was like
the amount of money I'm gonna make off
for the castle is going to be more than
pretty much all of my residential
properties like it's just gonna be
insane so I think that's something on a
smaller level on the state where I've
lost money I guess ultimately money
comes from people and in property you
money comes from tenants it's just okay
it's been just putting wrong tenants in
I'd rather have no tenant than a bad
tenant yeah I'd rather have a month's
void no one in the house but then put in
a really good tenant then move someone
interest right away
who's they're not gonna pay me rent so I
think I think being a bit more cheesy of
the tenants is something that's really
important as a landlord you talking
about the castle deal and we see that
was very exciting and I know that a lot
of people listening to this podcast
maybe have seen that or heard about it
did you find that a scary deal to do in
the beginning yeah it was yeah it was
scary but at the same time it's fun and
ultimately it's funny because sometimes
people think just cuz I've got a lot of
money now I must love money but actually
if I lost everything
I'd be very content with my family and
every life I'm alright I've lived in
I've lived in very
very small houses and stuff like growing
up single mom very small houses and you
know what living in a big house and
having lots of money in the bank having
a big portfolio it doesn't actually make
you feel that much happier like I'm okay
I'm doing it I'm doing it for different
reasons it's funny you say that because
I make you years ago we that originally
I think 2015 yes and I make you then and
we had a we had a conversation we spoke
we connected we had a heart-to-heart we
exchanged a few words and obviously I've
followed you over the years and I have
some very close friends who know you
very well and they know me very well and
obviously having the privilege and
obviously the pleasure to learn from you
today right as a successful businessman
I'm looking to expand my property
business you know seeing my father
investing property in South Africa
having my own seven figure property
portfolio in the Netherlands and
obviously looking now at Europe which is
the best market to go into and the UK is
buzzing sitting here with you and and
and obviously choosing who's the best
person to help you with this and you
know all all the feedback a semi elite
semi or leads it and so I've met you in
2015 and I'm sitting with you now it's
been time with you now you haven't
changed you're still passionate you
still you know you still it's the same
Samuel and this is I think a
misconception that people have is that
when you have a lot of money it changes
you
yes it can however you know being around
your wife and seeing your family I still
see the Samuel that I met years ago warm
kind generous I mean your family stepped
in yesterday I saw hugs I saw friendship
so a lot of love around you and do you
find that you know having the financial
changes that have happened obviously
have you find that a little bit as a
struggle sometimes to find the balance
between being so successful financially
and making such an impact on people's
lives inspiring people to change and
achieve their financial freedom do you
find that sometimes you can do
balance and become a little bit you know
money driven or maybe maybe you wanna
buy the toys and stuff do you find
yourself because I know you did a big
project in Uganda right yeah you helped
an amazing orphanage was it yes I've
done quite I've worked in orphanages
we're currently building a school I've
done a lot of water wells and things
like that I think to answer your
question I'm probably less money driven
now than I was when you met me five
years ago finally yes when you met I
became a millionaire at 25 which i think
is the year that we met it must have
been when I met you I instantly became a
millionaire fine but I didn't learn a
lot from you yeah but I think that when
you haven't got money sometimes you like
I need money I need money I need money
almost like if you're really hungry you
want food I'm hungry I want food
but then when you've just eaten you know
you're like leave it and then suddenly
you can share the pizza instead have
been your most greedy with food I know I
am when I don't get a big pizza when I
first get it yes and it's like oh my
gosh I've got this pizza you know you
can't have a slice but then when you
have a few slices you're something
thinking I'm kind of fall everyone help
yourself and I'm feeling the same way
that we've money you actually love money
less when you have it most of the people
that I know that love money have none
yeah
so for me I'm more relaxed now I focus
more on don't I do more within my
charity now which is just being
registered which is amazing then I ever
navigate five years ago and I don't
think money changes you I think it just
enables you to do what you actually want
to do if you want to be a jerk to people
if you want to flip flip the bird to all
the haters and you want to prove people
wrong and and and you want to you know
flush it flashy sports cars and show who
you're the daddy and all that kind of
stuff if that's what you want to do then
when you have money then that's what you
will do I'm not about that life I just I
just want to inspire people you know be
a good role model to my kids so it's
probably just enabled me to be more of
what I wanted to do anyway
and it's funny you say that you no role
model to your kids and and and because
obviously I have a son right my boys six
years old yeah and so for me it's always
about you know how can I help my
children how can I help the people that
I love
my tribe the people that I care about
and I think this is one of the magical
ingredients that has brought us together
today it's because you're very hard
driven mission driven and passionate
about helping other people there's a
story that I've heard before and I want
to put it put it on the table there's a
story of you having a list of names next
to your bed mm-hmm you've heard the
story right oh yeah of course
so you so it's come to my ears people
have said that next to Samuels bed
there's a list of people tell me a
little bit about this so it's something
that I started doing about two and a
half years ago which was every time
someone would become financially free I
it was actually a tie chart so every
time someone became financially Freud
put a little little tick next to it and
yeah of course names and stuff would go
with that and he just it just it just
went up but it just made me feel really
good seeing how many people had helped
become financially free leave their jobs
last year in 2019 I'm still counting up
exactly so I won't give a number right
now but it's over a hundred and and it's
just yeah I mean that that's that's my
currency you know seeing people succeed
is and some people think are whatever
that's just cheesy but but the thing is
when you give and you change someone's
life
believe me karma karma comes around yeah
you know so I can't member who was who
was it just said help enough people get
what they want and you get what you want
this exhibit is exhibiting if you help
enough people get what they want you
will surely get what you want yeah but I
think that's true in any business it's
always about adding value so as a result
of it of course I get the satisfaction
but also I get to do adventure with
people do deals yeah now you have a
flourishing company obviously you teach
people you train people you help them
achieve financial freedom you don't take
any money out of your company from my
training business I don't take a penny
from it that sums from my property
business believe me I take money from
that yeah from the training business how
they take money okay so you put it
everything back into the business yes
right and you charity cherry
so the training business yeah any
profits that we get we give to charity
we put back into the business to grow
the mission yeah very cool I don't take
money from me so when people say you
know are you just trying to you're just
trying to sell a dream to get money
people decided I just broke there's
always gonna be haters isn't there yeah
jealous or or skeptical or maybe they've
been burned yeah because there are
people in the in the end in the property
industry Baofeng by but in Landlord slum
landlords and then trainer yeah you know
charlatans that there's good and bad in
every industry yeah but yeah I don't
even take a salary I do from a mission
point of view yeah I got it I love that
let me ask you another question
how does your wife cook with this she's
fine yeah she's she's the most chilled
out awesome wife and and we go on a lot
of vacations so we travel a lot we just
got back from last month we were in
Thailand we're in Thailand we were
standing there most beautiful parts in
fact I think we we went to time to go
did way when you were doing empty yes
yes so I we I'm not sure if you were
with me in Thailand I think I was two
years in a row anyone happy I think
we've seated a lot I don't know yeah
well things we wouldn't know each other
if it wasn't the training programs of
course because we've been I've been to
some of your training programs we've
been delegates together it's funny you
say that because we touched on this in
one of our earlier conversations one of
the most undervalued benefits of taking
advanced training and advanced courses
is not necessarily the content and the
tools and and and all the strategies you
learn but it's the people you meet yeah
and this is something that I always say
to people if you're gonna you know take
any program remember you're gonna get
great tools you're gonna learn material
you're gonna equip yourself you're gonna
really get some really great ideas on
how to achieve your financial freedom
yeah but don't forget about the people
you're gonna meet I mean you were the
Eagles you are sitting with the Eagles
you're sitting with the people that want
no regrets yeah you're sitting with the
people that just want to go that are not
looking outside the window and waiting
for all the
perfect lights doing training programs
now for that reason and I'll go on the
most expensive training programs because
then I know I'll be with the best people
yeah you know so and I travel all over
the world doing it and an Amanda comes
with me you're asking about how many
deals with me I think that some people
would look at Amanda's like my wife and
they'll say like oh man how do you do it
such a hard life because I'm all over
the place training thousands of people
buying loads of properties final over
the world you know getting stopped in
the street and stuff people talking
about me constantly online good and bad
yeah
how does Amanda deal with that that's
terrible but at the same time on the
home a lot we travel a lot when we were
in Thailand I was gonna say it was
beautiful but then we were like she'll
go to Singapore for a bit so we just
went to Singapore for three days then we
went back to Thailand and we go away at
least two times a year to a exotic
beautiful country on our own no kids
fantastic twice a year let me ask you
one more thing so you're in property now
we just finished the decade 2019 we've
started 2020 what is semi all these big
goals for this this year I wanted to do
two deals two property deals in the
multi-million pound region well I'm
making millions of pounds profit two
deals last year I did 27 deals I don't
want to do 27 deals 2020 I don't want to
buy 27 houses I don't one out of
thousands of tenants I just wanted you
to do two and make millions of pounds
from them and that way it's about being
very choosy I'm just buying everything
being really cheesy and then making it
count
it's face rather than rather than
jabbing you the face yeah I'm just gonna
knock you out with a right hook yeah
that's 2020 I love I love would you say
being choosy one of the one of the
things that I've learned of it was
obviously from the Bill Gates and the
Warren Buffett's and the Oprah Winfrey's
and the Mark Zuckerberg and the Robert
Kiyosaki's they all say you've got to
exercise the power of no hmm the power
of saying no yeah cuz we have limited
time we have you know 24 hours a day
seven days a week and we're gonna get a
lot of opportunities and opportunities
obviously come to you as they do to me
but actually it's about saying no more
than saying yes
yeah and sometimes that's really hard
yeah so people are listening to this
podcast what would you say to them and I
know you've shed tons of golden nuggets
but what would you say to them for 2020
what would be a key thing to get them on
the property ladder get them on their
property journey well what what message
can you leave them with yeah I would I
would say it's a fantastic time to buy
property 2020 in the UK interest rates
are really low property prices are
actually pretty low believe it or not
depending on what depending on where you
go that I mean they've never given out
the banks have never given out money as
cheap as they give it our knows all but
they're almost handing out free money to
free money and to not take advantage of
that I just I just don't know how people
are gonna live with themselves in 20 40
years time when their grandkids say you
know what did you do when the banks were
giving out money at 3% it's just gonna
be an embarrassment so I would say
definitely buy property and I mean even
if you're even if you'll the property
doesn't go up in value super quick make
sure it cashflow is positive and I think
what I would say in 2020 is don't have
massive to-do lists just have a few
goals where if you achieve those few
things it would be a good year for you
and don't do anything that's not in the
directions they're bringing you to that
goal and whether that goal is going to
be a case of I'm gonna buy my first
property if by the end of 2020 I owned
the property there'll be a good year for
me right write that down it might be I
want to make 2 grand a month in passive
income or it might be I want to get out
of my job or I want to just I want to
get married I want to just write down
three or four things don't have 20
things I need to do list every day and
then when you wake up just focus on
achieving that and don't and act as if
you would die if that didn't happen I
love it when you say you know just have
three or four things I always I always
tell people get rid of your to-do list
yeah and instead create a not to do list
maybe because people are caught up with
[ __ ] that they shouldn't be doing yeah
there is not serving them yeah
and watching TV who hangs out in the pub
man
I mean honestly so someone said that to
me oh you know I haven't he does I said
what do you do what do you do on it on
an evening because this until halftime
and his partner said oh well you get out
to the pub do if you don't week I'm like
go down to the pub to hang with your
friends like come on yeah just pick up
the phone and make some calls and do
some deals and it's funny you say that
because I think it's underestimated how
easy it is to make those calls
once you first one might be a little bit
of a challenge second one okay it's
uncomfortable but yeah but once you get
used to it and you're willing to you
understand what you playing for yeah
what's on the line yeah yeah then you
like I do it I'll make calls all day
every day yourself in a good environment
in there like it's easy for us to make
calls because we've got like this
morning we're having breakfast we've got
all these cool people around us Marvin
was there yeah he's just awesome you
know it's it's cool man there's a good
vibe we're in the right kind of
environment if you're on your happy if
you're on your own and you've got a wife
or a husband who doesn't really believe
in what you're doing and then you've got
a boring job and then you get back and
it's tough
so get get yourself friends that are six
months ahead of where you want to be
it's finished I love when you say six
months I hear that people always say to
me they could come with a challenge or
they bring bring a problem or they're
stuck I always say look first of all
who's your role models and then you'll
get the Sir Richard Branson's you'll get
the you know Michael Jordan's you'll get
the Nelson Mandela's you get the Martin
Luther King's you know you get some
great names and I always say it's great
to have a role model but those are
long-term role models find a short-term
role model like you said find someone
who's just six months ahead of you yeah
12 months ahead of you or two or three
years ahead of you yeah but not someone
who's 20 or 30 years ahead of you yeah
because it's very easy get off track but
if you find someone who's like just a
year two ahead of you yeah sure it's
easy to keep in touch with their
progress yeah and then you catch them up
surpassed them to the point where then
you can be that
friend to them exactly get fine solving
the six months ahead of you and then
within six months become six months
ahead of that yeah so doing years work
in six months exactly and that's why I
think one of the cool things that I
found coming to the craft course is that
you've got people there who've become
successful by using your methods and
using your system and if you were just
to walk into property tomorrow and you
have no clue there people there that
you've trained that even calm and they
support you at the events some of your
crew who've just been doing this for six
12 18 months and they've got some
incredible stories and some great
results and these are great people to
connect with as well yeah and when I
know we've got an interview winners
Wednesday if anyone look because that
I'm sure as people listening that are
thinking this is this on dude I want to
hear more about his story well we'll put
a link above for YouTube and if it was
just another podcast do a search on
YouTube I'm on Bonaire Samuel leaves and
you'll see that interview but dude it's
been a pleasure chatting thank you
absolutely thank you for having me
inspiring stuff
[Music]
[Music]
you